so these these perspectives and many
other perspectives that that I would use
to kind of get over that anger that I
was feeling in the morning it helped and
it's a fairly yeah it helps helps
reframe the day but when I talk to you
about it I was at a point where
reframing was not working it was it was
working but it was working less and less
you can't keep putting band-aids on the
wound
right and I feel like I wake up in the
morning I'd be angry I put a bandaid on
it and then like the Bene start to come
off and then I put like another band-aid
on it right and then by the end of the
day I just got these layers of band-aids
so continue that metaphor it's you have
to bandage the wound before you can get
to the hospital so Swisher and these
perspective shifts are the the temporary
ban ya help out but let's talk about the
long-term perspective show yeah so um so
yeah I mean long story short man I got
ahold of a therapist a referral through
our physician dr. Ryan green and dude
it's funny like one-hour therapy like
how it really helped me reframe the way
I looked at the relationship so up into
this point it was I don't talk a lot
about my upbringing with Jehovah's
Witnesses I don't talk about your OVAs
witnesses too much because I really want
to respect people's beliefs and I really
want to respect people's values and I
don't I try to not talk about that
organization the watchtower tract
Society I tried to not talk about that
in a negative light because it's just
like any other religion in the sense
that it has you know a group of people
with a a bolita set belief of dogmatix
or am i repeating myself there but yeah
there's an ideology and and it works for
my dad and that's great but I always
looked at the reason why I preface it is
because I always looked at the problem
with my dad and I was this society and I
would always tell myself man if it
wasn't for the watchtower Ontrack
society if it wasn't for their
interpretation of the Bible then my dad
and I would have a really really great
relationship and that is where I was
getting stuck for two reasons one I
don't want to look at any organization
and be it and feel anger
or resentment yeah and plus that doesn't
feel right to me anyway to like sit
there and blame an organization know the
organization is making my dad do this
like that just doesn't feel right to me
so sure talking to sue the therapist
yeah it was it was a great man he just
helped me to kind of realize that yeah
man like my dad he is who he is right
and like the the religion that he is in
he uses he uses that as a tool to be a
bad dad he's a bad dad who uses the the
religion to bludgeon you but if it
weren't for the religion he would find
something else to bludgeon me with and
well the thing too is like well the the
therapist was like there are other
people in this religion that are in
similar circumstances to what you and
your father and right and he's like and
they they're still able to maintain
decent relationships with their kids
right and I'm like yeah you're
absolutely right like this is not this
is not a this is the the the a the
organization is not a the problem it is
a symptom of who my dad really is right
that makes any sense he's looking for
the problem right so so yeah long story
short um it feels like it's just having
that one hour conversation that was on
Monday so today's Thursday this is just
four days ago I haven't woken up angry
one time I mean I do wake up and like it
hurts and I'm like God I wish like I
could just call my dad and be like hey I
love you man how's it going when are we
going on at scuba diving trip but but
like I you know will wake up and like
have those random thoughts but instead
of me getting angry because I used to
just be like oh you see if you were just
if you would just see how misled he is
and and and it's like I don't have that
anymore
because it's not about him being misled
right it's just about him being a bad
dad I'm like that's okay man like I it's
funny because I've always what's okay
cuz you're not entitled to a good dad
yeah and you know I always looked at
like the relationship with my mother
back in the eighth grade when just you
know [ __ ] hit the fan with with with
that side of my family I got blamed yeah
as in junior high I got blamed for a lot
of what happened and I was able and I
was able to in junior high look at the
relationship with my mom I'd be like you
know what I don't know why I'm being
blamed for this stuff right now I don't
know why any of this is my fault in fact
it's not my fault and it turns out that
you know my mom's perspective is just
wrong and she's just not able to be a
good parent right now and I was able to
move on and it's like I don't know why
it took me until 37 years old to realize
that with my dad
but it was through this therapy session
that totally helped me to kind of to
just accept that really yeah but you
know I guess the other thing to get out
of this whole experience and the reason
why I'm sharing it is because if if
there is someone out there who is waking
up with a with you know some kind of
pain or some kind of inks on a regular
basis
yeah the temporary ban days will work
well temporarily it is so important to
go get the help that you need and it's
and it's not like like our conversations
help in fact when people when people
reach out to me for mentoring a lot of
the times they will tell me hey Ryan I
know I have a lot of good friends to
talk to and family to talk to but I know
what what your personality is like I
respect your opinion and your advice so
I just want to get an unbiased opinion
on a matter right so I can you know what
was someone that I respect and it was
the same thing with a therapist it's
like I want to you know well yeah the
other thing yeah I wanted to talk to
someone who I respected and he was a
great recommendation from dr. Ryan green
who like really talked him up but the
other thing too is like I'm thinking all
right Ryan I have got the typical
the stereotypical like Freud mommy and
daddy issues so why don't I go and do
the stereotypical treatment for it right
and it turns out like it's it's a
stereotype for reason yeah and and it
was helpful and guess what if it wasn't
helpful you wasted an hour of your life
and a little bit of money yeah and at
least you're one step closer to figuring
out what the long-term perspective shift
is so what the reason I I bring these
two different solutions up is getting
the short-term perspective shift is
important as long
you're willing to do something about it
long-term as well and so finding finding
what that change is for you it could be
as simple as as reframing the idea that
lay it's not a bad religion necessarily
it's a bad parent yeah it's it was yeah
it was reframing the the way I looked at
my dad like instead of using something
else to blame for my dad and i's
relationship being able to look at my
dad and just be like dude this is not it
has nothing to do with religion this has
nothing to do the watchtower tract
society this has everything to do with
you as a person because of war for
religion he would use geography or money
or any other excuse to to beat you over
the head with that right and any other
sort of resource or ideology that that
it was useful and because the
conversation you and I had like even
when you're growing up and you were
being a good Jehovah's Witness oh yeah
yeah he going out going door-to-door on
a regular basis maybe we have any single
every single meeting which is just
another term for going to church and
dude like when I was there I think they
cut it back but when I was there it was
like three days a week going for an hour
or two hours yeah I was doing everything
I was supposed to do and even then he
found fault still found a way house in
oh I'll do weather cuz I was working for
him at the time so there's always you
know riding me at work with every little
thing that he could find yeah I mean
just insert random not in a little paper
no not in a loving way not in a way that
helps you grow yeah I mean just you know
any any random excuse you could think of
in a wallpaper in painting business to
like criticize someone like he was just
right on top of it and I understand
because this he is raising his standards
for me and I and I understand that um
you know he's going to try and get me to
get to those standards
yeah but to your point the standards
that he's trying to get to trying to get
me to now I was already there right and
he still was a bad dad and I think about
my sister it's the same thing I mean she
was doing you know it's like my dad
would be like okay you need to to my
sister you need to go you need to go
door to door
so then she would and then he'd be like
okay that's great you're doing good but
you need to go even more now so then she
upped her hours to you know 30 hours a
month or 40 hours I forget what it like
what the what the what the the timeframe
is that they require to tube they call
it what I'm not gonna get into the
jargon but my point is is that so then
yeah she go out door-to-door more and
then my dad like that's great now make
sure that you are dating someone when
she got to the age to date make sure
you're dating someone that is is in the
watchtower on track Society so then she
would great she found someone who was in
the washer on track Society well it
turns out he wasn't he wasn't enough of
a person for her to date because he
wasn't an elder in the in the in the
church or he was so there was always
there is always this standard that my
dad would have we meet it and then he
raises it and that is a symptom of him
that is not a symptom of anything else
which by the way is great if you are
raising standards for reason that's what
we should be doing so when we have these
arbitrary standards and not even
standards anymore it becomes an
unrealistic expectation
yeah and it's always going to be the
next thing that is out of reach I'm
always gonna find something
that is out of reach for you yeah it's
it's the all you can dunk on a 13 foot
rim hello you're 14 here's 13 and a half
yeah dude it's it's always like raising
that bar but dude it's it's totally okay
to raise one standards it's okay for me
to raise my standards raise my standards
every day if I can but I will never
raise your standards for you I will
never go out of my way to make you feel
bad yeah because I've set a standard for
you in my head and you're not there like
you're my best friend dude like I will
support you no matter what and if you
need help if you ask me for help with
your standards that you set for yourself
great I'll help you but I'm not gonna
come to you and say these are my
standards and you're not living up to
them and you should feel bad about it
and that sounds like a whole lot of
shitty relationships yeah a lot of
shitty relationships that's why they're
shitty is because we try to impose our
standards our beliefs our resources our
desires our and even our values onto
other people yeah and we do that
not only are we it's not setting the
example because that's not what your dad
was doing I'm gonna set the example for
you in fact it was off in the opposite
yeah it was do as I say not as I do
and and by doing that by it by by trying
to impose my Val if I'm living up to
them if I impose it on you you're not
it's it's the thing that I always say is
you know people don't hate change they
hate being changed right and because we
all like certain change like I got
promotion at work or wow we got a new
podcast studio that's a change like
those are changes that we you really
embrace because we went after it right
whereas the difference is if someone
says all right guys all right the
minimalist we're putting you in a new
podcast studio like wait what yeah or or
you know you're getting a demotion at
were or whatever like in fact I took the
demotion to work once member I I I
eliminated the job that I was in so I
got back into another job that was more
ideal for me
yeah and that was great but if someone
were to force me into it it's like being
changed we don't like being changed so
trying to change someone is never going
to work at least not long-term you know
it's funny man I support people's values
and beliefs as much as possible go out
of my way to not just support but
appreciate the differences in people's
values and beliefs but what I don't
support is when it is affecting the
well-being of other people like that's
where that's where I will step up and be
like hey you're insane
you